as we were saying Dylan roof a white
supremacist killed nine people at the
Charleston Church in 2015 during a Bible
study the congregation which is still
healing from the tragedy is now coming
together to pray for and support
Charlotte ville chip Reid is outside
Emanuel AME in downtown Charleston chip
good morning good morning this church
here in Charleston is affectionately
known as mother Emanuel it is the oldest
African Methodist Episcopal Church in
the south and yes they know heartache
all too well but they also know how to
forgive I thank God for his who said it
grace at other Emmanuel Church in
Charleston the healing will never end
[Music]
parishioners here know how hate can
affect a community but they continue to
preach forgiveness despite the wounds
that were ripped open over two years ago
[Music]
gunmen entered the Emanuel AME Church
last night during a prayer meeting
he killed the pastor and eight
parishioners I think what the world
forgets said each time we come back here
we come back to a crime scene we have to
get to that every day Willie Glee and
Cynthia Amos have been parishioners at
mother Emanuel for years the white
supremacy march in Charlottesville did
it bring back what happened here for you
I think there's a lesson in
Charlottesville that should come to all
Americans you have a nation that does a
lot of talk about race there's a lot of
talk about social justice but very few
people are doing anything about it some
people just get crazy and they don't
realize that what they're doing to their
brother or their sister and it bothers
me hurts it hurts when they march with
torches and say the things they're
saying yes yes
I think this blame on both sides earlier
this week President Trump was criticized
for equating the white nationalist who
marched on Charlottesville with the
counter protesters how would you like to
see the current president react to this
[Applause]
leadership is everything and he's not
providing it right now
that's a port interpretation pastor Eric
Manning has been leading mother Emanuel
Church since last June
one year after Dylan roofs horrific
attack from what you went through is
there any advice you can give them on
how to deal with being on the receiving
end of this kind of hatred it is hard to
forgive but aspire to forgive aspire to
love because if you continue to carry
hatred in your heart it will become
cancerous and it will begin to tear the
community further apartment do you think
that these people who are spewing racist
hate can embrace love at some point or
are they lost causes I would have to
believe they can we think about the song
Amazing Grace right
pinned by a former slave trader
and son by and Sun by everyone right and
President Obama of course saying in
theology as well so surely people can
change the question is are we going to
be an agent for that change or are we
going to further spew the negative
hatred that we know does not do anyone
any good how do you fight that kind of
hatred
I know it's hard isn't it it's
challenging we have to continue to pray
one for another and even forgive them
and even forgive them pastor Manning
told me that Bible study here always
begins with the discussion of biblical
text but inevitably it moves on to
current events last night it was
Charlottesville that weighed heavily on
their minds Nora Joan in that
conversation a really perfect tone and
I'm glad we went back there to talk to
them really needed at this time grain